back in july 2014 a federal judge
declared dc's ban on carrying handguns
in public unconstitutional well since
then thousands have obtained a concealed
carry permit after taking at least 18
hours of training from a metropolitan
police department certified firearms
instructor now the very first person to
become
one of those instructors was also the
first one to get a concealed carry
permit in the district of columbia i
happen to know him his name is leon
spears and he joins me now
leon
i think you were the first person to
call me
aft i think it was within a half hour
after this ruling came down
what what do people need to know
about what this means
and why this is good news for the
average person out there who is scared
in the streets of urban america
well nice to nice to see you laura as
always
first off there are really like four
points
uh the first point is that obviously
the constitution was upheld today
so you have a right to carry a firearm
outside of your home so heller decided
that you can keep a firearm inside your
home for self-defense so this is
considered um just groundbreaking
because again you can defend yourself
outside of your home then the second
thing is okay so once you are able to
carry outside your home then how are you
caring are you caring openly or
concealed so if you are allowed by the
state's provisions to carry concealed
then it goes to step three okay so how
can you carry concealed either
restrictions
so you can have restrictions on training
how long the training is
you can have magazine capacities you
could have fingerprints
photos
background checks those are all the
requirements then you can have sensitive
places
schools
fully owned and operated by the
government structures
cares hospitals you can have limitations
for sensitive places but again then you
can go to reciprocity and recognition so
let's say you're allowed to carry but
then sure enough what does that state
say do do they recognize another state
concealed carry permit or better yet um
is there a reciprocity agreement amongst
attorney generals or governments that
allow each other to consider conceal in
each other's jurisdictions so many
people don't understand that today was a
great day for
gun ownership and empowerment for people
to be able to defend themselves now i
want to play something from msnbc's
yamiche alcindor watch
talking to people who are advocates for
new gun laws and new gun restrictions
this is devastating to them they feel
like this is going to make america less
safe we have people that think in blue
state that they're in some ways
protected from that that if you live in
new york or california that you somehow
will not have to deal with the sort of
conservative things that you see
happening in other states
leon you're less safe
because of this does that make any sense
given your extensive background in
firearms training to help people get
these concealed carry permits
it's so empowering to teach people in dc
about
the ability to carry a firearm how i
don't know how many people
are my clients that actually are just
empowered that number one they have the
ability to carry defend themselves and
their families
they want to be law abiding and the
criminals are choosing every day
not to
not to go by the strenuous process of
buying a gun getting trained
getting background checks giving getting
government approval
the bad guys are not doing that people
just want to be able to defend
themselves to the best of their ability
and that's what the supreme court said
today yeah leon everyone has to everyone
has to understand that
to get these concealed carry permits
nothing that the court said today
diminishes
all of the requirements set by various
jurisdictions all it says is once you
have all that you can't be denied
arbitrarily the right to carry concealed
so
none of these people have read the
decision none of the people know
anything about the law but they're doing
the histrionic thing to try to scare
people for political reasons but leon
you made it so clear for us thank you so
much it is great to see you tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else